JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hi,
everyone, I'm John McCutchan.
TODD TURNIDGE: I
am Todd Turnidge.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We work
on Observatory together.
So Observatory is
a web application
that's hosted by the VM.
It provides a suite of program
inspection analysis tools.
Everyone on the Dart VM
team uses Observatory almost
every day, so we're
extremely committed to making
this tool really powerful.
And every time you come to us
with a performance problem,
the first thing we do is we
look inside of Observatory.
For those of you who
don't know, Observatory
is written in Polymer and Dart.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah,
and a little bit
of an agenda for our talk.
John's going to give a demo
of how he uses Observatory.
I'm going to demo some
of the new debugger
features in Observatory.
Then we'll go on to talk
in general about the tool.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right, so
I'm going to demo something
that I do on a regular
basis in my day job,
which is stare at Box2D
performance in Observatory.
TODD TURNIDGE: So what's Box2d?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So Box2D
is a physics engine.
There's benchmarks
built around it
that everyone likes to
compare the performance
of different VMs and runtimes,
so it's really important
that the Dart VM
runs Box2D well.
TODD TURNIDGE: Let's
increase the font size a bit,
or it doesn't matter.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Actually,
it's mostly visual, so.
All right, so the first
thing I'm going to do
is I'm just going to
click on one of the tests,
and this is just a
simple blob test program.
And now I'm going to
connect to Observatory.
So in the past, we
had Observatory baked
into dev tools, but
we found that kind
of cramped Observatory's
style, because Observatory
likes to have lots of links and
the browser-like navigation.
So now we just print a link
in the console that takes you
to Observatory for this demo.
Now, the main page in
Observatory lists the isolates,
and we can see that
we have one isolate,
and it's called Blob Test,
which is the program that we're
running on the other tab.
So if I click on the
Blob Test isolate,
it takes us to the main
page for the isolate, where
we can see information about
race and execution history,
links to various tools that
are built into Observatory,
information about the heap.
What I'm going to do next
is go to the root library
for this isolate, and
this is the library that
contains the main function.
So when we're looking
at a library page,
we see the other libraries
that this library's imported,
the scripts inside of it,
the classes contained,
and functions contained.
Now, all of these are
just regular hyperlinks
that you can open up a new
tabs and browse around and even
share.
So why don't I start
with the blob test class.
So now we're looking
at a classes page,
and I'm going to go up here
and click Refresh Coverage.
So this class has
three functions.
Here's some information about
instances that we'll get to,
but let's just take a
look at code coverage.
TODD TURNIDGE: What's
the green mean?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
So the green means
that this is an executable
line that has executed.
And if there's no color next to
it, the line is not executable.
You can see this is
just a closing brace.
There's no statement
on this line.
So if we scan
through this class,
we can see that actually every
single line in this class
has executed, which makes
sense, because this just
sets up the demo, which
is already running.
Why don't we try
and find some code
that hasn't executed, so we
can see what that looks like.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to click on this,
and this is showing runtime type
feedback for this line of code,
so this method invocation
of new polygon shape,
we actually see that
it's of this class,
and this is the
class's constructor.
So why don't I click over
to the polygon shape class,
and we'll take a look.
Now we're on a
polygon shape class,
and I'm trying to find some
code that hasn't executed,
so we can see what that
looks like in Observatory.
So I scroll down.
We see some green.
Here's some red, more red.
So the red is these
lines are executable,
but they haven't executed yet.
Here's this function
Set As Edge,
which hasn't executed yet.
Why do we actually, while
the program is still running,
just execute it and
see what happens.
So to do that, I'm
going to go up here,
and I'm going to find instances
of the polygon shape class.
TODD TURNIDGE: So these are the
strongly reachable instances
of polygon shape?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yep,
these are instances
inside your program's heap that
are still alive in this class.
So I'll just command click
and open up a new tab,
and now we're actually
looking at a specific instance
of the polygon shape.
Now I could just go
down here on this line
and start typing
regular Dart code.
So I'll just try and execute
this set as edge function.
OK, so that function
ran an it returned
null, which is what we expect.
Now let's go back over here.
And we can see that-- sorry,
we'll go back over here,
and I'll refresh code coverage.
And we can see that we have
executed this line of code.
Now why don't I go ahead and
load up a different demo.
I'll try this domino tower.
So I'll go back to the
Observatory main page,
and now we can see that we have
a new isolate for this tab.
And I'll show you another
feature in Observatory
called the Allocation Profile.
So at the top of the
Allocation Profile,
you have high level information
about both of your heaps,
how big they are,
how many collections
have occurred, how frequent
the collections are.
And then underneath,
we have a break
down on a class-by-class
basis of allocations.
So we can see that the most
allocated class in this program
is double, which makes
sense, because it's a physics
simulation, so you'd
expect a lot of doubles
and other floating point types.
List, we can't conclude
much, because they're
so common in Dart already.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah,
it's not a smoking gun.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No,
but one byte string,
this actually looks
really strange.
This is a physics
simulation, and somehow we've
allocated over a million
strings, or a mega string.
TODD TURNIDGE: A mega string.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
So why don't we--
I think this looks really
weird, because after a one byte
string, we see Float64Array,
main to vector two.
These all make a lot of sense
for what this program is doing.
Something strange is
happening, and why don't we
try and figure out
what's going on.
So in order to
figure out the rate
that we're allocating
one byte strings,
I'm going to reset
the accumulator.
And this accumulator's
a counter that I zero,
and then we increment
every time we allocate
an instance of that class.
So I'll reset the counter,
switch back over to the demo,
and let this run for,
let's say, five seconds.
I'll come back,
and I'll refresh.
So we can see in five
seconds we actually
allocated almost two million
new instances of string.
This is really
bizarre, and we need
to figure out what's going on.
So why don't we go
over to the CPU profile
and see if we see anything
string-related that's hot.
So we're looking at
the CPU profile now,
and we see these different
categories, like Dart, Native,
GC New Space.
Dart is the category that's
set when we're actually
executing script code.
TODD TURNIDGE: So Dart is
the stuff that you all write,
basically?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, exactly,
and so if we skim down here,
I'm looking for
something string-related.
We see stuff around vector
two calling sign and QoS.
This all fits.
And down here at about 1.76%,
we see string one byte string
concat all, so something is
doing string concatenation,
but we don't know what yet.
So if I expand this, we can
see who's triggering the string
concatenation, and we see
that string concatenation
is being triggered by
string base interpolate.
TODD TURNIDGE: So we're
seeing the callers
here as we open it up?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Exactly, so
interpolate calls concat,
and the canvas
rendering context set
fill color and set stroke
color RGB call string base
interpolate.
None of this is my code.
Canvas rendering context
2D is part of Dart HTML.
But underneath this we can
see canvas draw set color.
This is actually part of
the Box2D demo harness.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to open this up
in another tab, and we can
look at what the source
code of this function does.
Now, this function gets
a color as a vector,
and it passes in
the vector contents
for red, green,
blue and then passes
in a hard coded alpha value.
TODD TURNIDGE: It
looks innocent.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I don't
see any string interpolation
going on here at all or really
have any intuition as to why
we would be doing that.
So why do we actually dig
in and look at the Dart HTML
implementation of
this function, which,
because we're running
in Observatory,
and we have access
to all source code,
we can actually
take a look at this.
And we see the smoking
gun right away.
We see that even
though we're passing
in the color as integers,
immediately a string
is interpolated of RGBA, and
then this string is passed off
to the Dom.
So even though we've gone
to all of this trouble
to keep the color as integers,
every single time we set it
on the canvas, we're
indirectly allocating a string,
or, in our case, two strings.
So why don't we see if
we can fix this, and just
like a cooking show,
I am going to--
TODD TURNIDGE: It's ready
to come out of the oven.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, and then
I'll go ahead an load up--
TODD TURNIDGE: In fact, what
do you call this project?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: This
is the turkey project.
The turkey Is done, and
it's fixed, so let's see.
So I'll go back to domino tower,
bringing up Observatory again,
and I'm going to hop over
to the Allocation Profile,
and i come down here.
I'm going to reset
the accumulator again.
I'm going to let this run
for about five seconds.
I come back over here,
and I'm going to refresh.
And we can see that one byte
string has now fallen way down.
It's now only 1,000 strings
are allocated in every five
seconds versus two million,
so this is a drastic reduction
in GC pressure and allocation.
TODD TURNIDGE: Could be worse.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Could be a lot worse.
But now let's go back
over to the CPU profile
and see if we can see
this one byte string
function as being hot.
I don't see it.
TODD TURNIDGE: I think that all
the calls were from that thing,
so all the string
interpolation you've probably
removed at this point.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Yeah, I think so.
TODD TURNIDGE: That's
1 and 1/2% you've
pulled out of the benchmark.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Yeah, so 1 and 1/2%
faster of running
this benchmark demo,
and we were relegating
a lot less memory,
so all in all, a net win.
Let's go back to the slides.
All right, so what
did we just see?
Well, you saw me browsing
through the running program,
looking at live code coverage.
I was able to inspect
specific instances,
locate instances of classes
that I was interested in,
invoke code on a
running instance.
We looked at the
Allocation Profile,
which is per class statistics
and per heaps garbage space
information as well.
We use the user controllable
accumulated to figure out
how many strings we're
actually allocating,
and then we use the CPU
profile to go and find
the smoking gun that was
actually triggering all
of these string allocations.
So now I'm going to
turn over to Todd.
He's gong to give
you a debugger demo.
OK
TODD TURNIDGE: So,
the debugger's sort
of a fresh feature
in Observatory,
very recently added,
all done in 2015.
And I'm going to show
you the debugger, finding
a bug in an actual program.
Now this program is one
that I wrote with my kids.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
My kids, I want to teach them
programming, the family trade,
so we're writing a
text adventure game.
So this will be the second
game demo you've seen today--
significantly more low tech.
So you're in a
mysterious chamber.
There's an exit to the west.
A deadly mousetrap lies nearby.
For those of you
who aren't familiar,
a text adventure game,
you type in commands like
'take mousetrap,' and then
you're holding a mousetrap,
and you can take your inventory,
and you're holding one.
You can around.
You can go-- oh, here's
a rusty revolver,
so I'll take the revolver.
We'll go south.
Now there's a bug in
this program, which
is my kids want you to be
able to fire the revolver
and to have something
delightful happen in the game.
So let's try to
shoot the revolver.
It says, it's too
rusty to shoot.
That's not the bug yet, so
I'll all take the oil can.
I'll oil the revolver,
and now I'll shoot it.
And boy, we'll be amazed.
No, it's still to
rusty to shoot.
Here's our bug.
We will use the Observatory to
find this bug in our program.
So let's go over to the browser
and bring up Observatory.
So here we are, back
at that initial page,
where we show all the isolates.
I'm just going to hop
straight to the debugger,
and what you're seeing
here is a split window.
The top will display the
frames, and the bottom
is a console that has
some input and output.
You can type commands,
much as you can in GDP.
Like if I type help, it
lists all the commands
that are available right now.
It has standard stuff
like setting and removing
breakpoints, printing
expressions, continuing,
pausing.
It's basically what you would
expect in a command line
debugger.
So let's set a break at main.
And I have tab completion
here, so I'll hit tab there.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So this
tab completion works for--
TODD TURNIDGE:
--functions-- so like main,
but also for scripts.
I'll do main.dart line
92, which I happen to know
is the code that's going to
handle the shoot command.
So I'll set that break
point, and then I'll
come back over here and
shoot the revolver again.
And it's frozen,
which is good, right?
That's a breakpoint.
So we come back over
to the debugger,
and we can see that we
actually have frames up here,
and I can expand
and contract frames.
Each frame, when I
expand it, shows me
sort of a cut out of the code.
It shows me a current position.
It also shows me, off to
the side, local variables
that I can expand and inspect.
But let's look at
our top frame here.
We are at line 92,
and let's print
an expression like player.
So player is the
object that holds
all information about a player.
Let's show some browsing.
So here's a player.
It has a current room.
The player has an
inventory with three items.
Let's see what I'm carrying.
I'm carrying a mousetrap.
I'm carrying a revolver,
and I'm carrying an oil can.
So this all agrees
with what I've
seen so far in the program.
Going back to the debugger,
let's single step.
So I'm going hit
end to single step.
I'll hit Return to
do the next command.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So, one of
the coolest things here,
and it might not be obvious
because of the font size,
but you actually see the blue
cursor move column by column,
so you see exactly
what part of the code
is going to execute next,
so that's pretty nice.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah,
that change was actually
within the same line.
so yeah, that little
blue box there,
that's what you're looking for.
And here we have the item.
Let's see what item it
is we're about to shoot.
It is the revolver.
And looking below, we
see that it has a field
called Can Shoot, which
is currently false.
This is going to be
the cause of our bug,
but let's just pretend
we don't know that yet.
We step.
If the item dot
can shoot is true,
it's going to do something.
Oh, it skips it.
OK, so the revolver's
still too rusty to shoot.
Let's continue to go
back and shoot it again.
This time, we're going
to use Observatory
to modify the data as we go
and actually explore the branch
that we intended it to go down.
So step, step, up arrow-- I
have command line history.
Let's print the
item dot can shoot.
It's false.
Now I'm going to set it
to true and continue.
And now it should
be the big surprise.
Success-- the revolver
backfires and we die.
Welcome to my children.
So let's go back to
the presentation here.
That's sort of a
taste of the debugger.
I didn't show you some of the
isolate management features.
We have the ability
to switch isolates
from within the debugger
and to rename isolates.
So if you've got a bunch of
them, you can give one of them
a distinguished name and
know what it is you're doing.
A second feature it has that dev
tools doesn't, is that protocol
supports multiple clients.
So John can be
running a debugger,
and I can be running a
debugger on the same exact VM
at the same time.
When I step through
the program, he'll
see the program state change.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's really
awesome to see it live.
Maybe later today, if you stop
us, we'll give you a demo.
TODD TURNIDGE: That's
a little bit too much
of a high wire act for up here.
But it's also nice
maybe working at home.
You can have a connection there.
So next page-- now
we're going to talk
about when we're adding features
to the Observatory, what
it is we think about as
were designing features.
The first is that
we should always
be collecting information.
The VM knows a lot
about your program.
It has your script.
It has your source.
It has parsed it.
It's turned it into
classes and functions.
It's compiled those
functions, and then it's
run those functions.
All of these things,
it knows exactly what's
happening all the time.
It also knows the heap, and
because it's garbage collected,
it knows where every single
object is in your program,
and you should have all this
information available to you
while it's running in real time.
I mean, there's no excuse
for every VM in the world
not to provide this information
to you all the time.
In addition to that, we
have a sampling profiler.
It's low overhead and always on.
So when you connect
up to the VM,
it's already got the
profile sitting there,
and you can already figure
out what it's been up to.
Second point-- the
Observatory is self-hosting.
Meaning it's built
into the Dart VM.
When you open up the
port, it'll serve it out,
so it's always available.
Observatory is like the turtle.
It carries its
shell on its back.
Its always home.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So another
design principle we have is
that we want you to be able to
observe the running program.
Though there's a lot of
great tools out there
that require you to start your
program with a special flag
or run it in a special harness,
this makes it really difficult
to diagnose real world
problems that you only
encounter in production.
So even if you forget to run
with the command line flag that
enables the Observatory
HTTP server,
you can just send your process
on the server the quit signal,
and that's going to trigger the
HTTP server to be activated,
and then you can connect.
And since we've always been
collecting the information,
we have all the
historical information.
You can actually
dig in and diagnose
what's happened after the
fact without needing to run
in a special environment.
It really helps you diagnose
problems in the wild.
TODD TURNIDGE: So manipulating
the running program--
you saw John call set as
edge and change the coverage
information as went.
I changed the can shoot
property of the revolver
and made it backfire.
But in a real
world scenario, you
could do something
like turn on logging.
You've forgotten
to enable logging.
You want to see the
logging messages.
You connect up to
the Observatory.
You tell it to evaluate logger
dot enable and the top level
root library evaluation area.
And then suddenly you've
got logging output
coming out of your program
without restarting it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So we've kind
of mentioned this already,
but we wanted to
support from day one
the idea that Observatory
on the service protocol
is a multi-user
collaborative experience.
So when you have-- every page
in Observatory has a unique URL.
So when you have
this URL, and you
go through the necessary
port forwarding steps
to forward from local host
to your external address,
I could take this URL.
I could chat it to Todd.
Todd could then paste
it into his browser,
and he's looking at the exact
same page in Observatory
that I am in the
running program.
TODD TURNIDGE: So to reiterate,
when you start this up,
it starts on local host.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, and
you have to full local host,
if you want to share.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And if you want
to share something externally,
you have to go through
the necessary steps
on your operating
system for the port.
But if you go
through those steps,
then you could even chat.
You could send a link somewhere
on the other side of the world
and debug together.
So finally, we want to build
an ecosystem for tools, so
every single thing that
you see in Observatory,
every interaction we do
with your running program
happens over the VM
service protocol.
And this for service protocol
is available to anyone,
allowing you to create
custom tools that
extract just that piece of
information you care about.
And we're also working with IDEs
to do deeper IDE integration,
where the IDE communicates
over the service protocol
and serves up
interesting information.
Examples internally-- we
have a code coverage tool,
that after all running the
unit tests in the Google source
base, that exports
the code coverage out
to this shared dashboard, and
it gets that information off
of the service protocol.
TODD TURNIDGE: To
that end, pretty soon
we're going to be publishing
draft one of the service
protocol.
We're still tidying
it up right now.
But the details of
this protocol are
that it's uses
something like JSON RPC,
so the requests and
responses are JSON,
and it uses WebSockets.
It should be pretty
familiar to people.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So take a
look at for Dart announce,
we'll have an announcement
in the next coming weeks.
TODD TURNIDGE: So, what
have we been doing?
Since last time we gave a
presentation on Observatory,
some of the new features
have been the debugger,
which we've shown you before.
That's pretty fresh.
Additionally, I want to talk
about annotated script view.
There's a person on our
team, Ryan-- Ryan Macnak--
and he says that the more
information you can associate
with the program source,
the more understandable
it is for people, because
you're showing them
like runtime information
associated with the stuff they
actually wrote.
And so we're trying to
provide more and more script
annotations in the program.
And John showed you this
with call site information.
He clicked on that
one constructor
and was able to show us the
actual constructor that' got
invoked at that line of code.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Both the
class and the method.
TODD TURNIDGE: Both the
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So
kind of furthering
that point of tying things
back to the source code
that you wrote, the CPU
profiler now understands
function in-lining.
So, in the past, if you
looked at the profile,
you might see one function
that kind of had globbed up
and in-lined lots and
lots of other functions
that your program is executing.
That made sense the compiler
engineers and people
on the VM team.
It was obvious
what was going on.
But for a regular
Dart developer,
who doesn't understand the
ins and outs of the compiler,
it can sometimes be confusing.
So now the profiler
understands in-lining
and will expand
it out so you see
the call stack that
makes sense to you,
the author of the program.
We also have metrics,
so user programs can now
provide counters and gauges.
And Observatory can connect
and sample these things
and show you a live counter.
Like, for example,
a server might
have how many clients are
connected to me right now,
and you can go in and watch
a graph like a dashboard
in Observatory.
TODD TURNIDGE: OK, so
what's coming next?
We're going to improve
debugging quite a bit.
Right now, we have some weakness
around developer workflow.
Specifically I edit my
program, and I want to restart.
I have to actually reconnect
to the Observatory.
It would be nice if
within Observatory, you
could support VM
restarts or even
individual isolate restarts.
That would be a nice addition.
We're going to work on that.
Additionally, you saw my demo.
I was switching back and
forth to standard out
to look at my output
for my program.
There's a reason
the standard out
and other streams shouldn't be
broadcast within the console
in the debugger window.
In fact, it would be
nice to be able to say,
when this future completes, let
me know in the dividing console
and have it print that out, too.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
that would be great.
So we want to have
a timeline view.
So right now, the profiler's
a statistical average of where
your program's spending time.
But sometimes you need to
pinpoint a specific time range.
So we're going to add a timeline
view that indicates things
like when method
compilations occur
or when a garbage
collection occurs,
and let you see
how that interacts
with your running program.
We also want to be able to
answer the question of where
do I allocate class Foo and
only class just class Foo?
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah,
just class Foo.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No.
We want to give you
an allocation call
sites for any class in your
program, so you can narrow in.
TODD TURNIDGE: Last,
as we were saying
before, we want to display
runtime information
alongside the source,
using the source
as a model for
exploration of the stuff
in a way that's understandable.
So the source code should
be live, hyperlinked view
into all of this
information that we have,
that, so far, hasn't been
shared with the user.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Yeah, I can't wait
until I can hover over a
variable and see its value.
TODD TURNIDGE: Or its guard
class, or whether it's
nullible or whatever.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Anything that
we can collect at runtime.
So, where can you
use Observatory?
Well, we've already
said this many times,
but Observatory is available
everywhere the VM is.
So you can use it for server,
command line applications,
for developing Sky
applications, which
you'll hear about tomorrow,
any web applications running
in Dartium.
Observatory is available
there, and we're also
integrating with IDEs,
like Sublime, Dart Editor,
and Webstorm, so that there's
buttons to launch and connect
to Observatory for
the running program.
Finally, Observatory is a suite
of development tools bundled
with the VM.
That means you already have it.
Everyone here has this, so
please try it out, and send us
bug and feature feedback.
We really want to
make sure that this
is useful to everyone,
and the best way
that we can do that
is to hear from you.
TODD TURNIDGE: We want
to make this the tool
that you use to write your
server-side Dart code.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
So, on this slide,
you can see Daniel and Ryan, two
other members of the Dart team
that help us with Observatory.
So feel free to grab
any of us if you
want to talk about Observatory
later on today and tomorrow.
Thanks.